he is the new deal with North Korea
actually a deal is good for the United
States can we trust the North Koreans to
follow it Doug McGregor is retired US
Army colonel author of the book margin
of victory congressman Jeff Fortenberry
is a Republican represents the state of
Nebraska and both of them join us
tonight
congressman first to you is this a deal
Americans ought to be happy about well
the best word that I can use to describe
the last few days in my mind is stunning
I think the president's actions here are
bold they're historic it's almost
unimaginable given where we were just
six months ago where we were on the
precipice of some type of even potential
nuclear exchange the president has
leaned into something pretty radical
here and perhaps he's creating a new
architecture for 21st century diplomacy
he has said to Kim Jong Jong we're going
to deal with you for good or for ill and
if it's for ill and you move your finger
toward a nuclear button we're gonna hurt
you but if it's for good I want to
create the space for perhaps authentic
dialogue and even friendship and I think
he accomplished that he has rejected the
norms of ossified procedural ISM and
stagnation that governs so many
international affairs and he took a bold
risk and I think he delivered something
very important it's his first step we
are holding out hope obviously for a
greater vision that could evolve here
but it's an important and good first
step ossified procedural ISM a phrase
I'm stealing colonel are you as
optimistic about it extremely I think
this is Donald Trump's finest hour and
I'm absolutely serious this is Donald
Trump has recognized something that
others have refused to see for a very
long time in Washington it's not simply
that North Korea is on the ropes it is
it's on the verge of collapse Donald
Trump understood that and that's one of
the reasons he was able to put the
pressure on North Korea the way he did
but he also went to great lengths in his
meetings with the president G to forge
an understanding with China he treated
President Xi as an equal treated China
isn't equal and I think Donald Trump
understands something that is not well
understood in the Pentagon at this point
or in many other places in Washington
and that our competition with China is
essentially economic and technological
it is not military and that was the key
development because without China none
of this would have happened
yes that's right and I think it clearly
stemmed from what he said about trade
with China congressman there's been a
lot of criticism of this deal from the
left along the lines that the president
is giving away important American
advantages in exchange for nothing how
would you respond to that this is the
combination of foreign policy realism
and entrepreneurial diplomacy and as I
said this is not only about potentially
preventing a conflict and opening up a
new chapter and in rejecting a stalemate
of the last 65 years with North Korea
but it also could signal a new way a new
architecture for diplomatic relations
moving forward look the world is
screaming for some type of new
interpersonal ecosystem both in our
homes and in our communities as well as
between nations and what that means is
that we have to have the ability to
reach out and provide authenticity and
dialogue and create some space because
the world is racing toward destructive
technology and then what civilization
itself is at stake and we've got to find
a way talk forward toward mutuality and
well-being and mutual security and or
else we're weird we don't have much hope
but I mean Colonel that's a lot of what
we have heard liberals and some
conservatives by the way criticized the
idea that you meet with someone who is
morally out-of-bounds like Kim jong-un
going forward should we be willing to
meet with anybody
oh absolutely and I think Donald Trump
is a disruptive force let's be frank
he's disrupting the status quo lots of
people in this town are very upset
because this threatens to change the
distribution of cash this threatens
budgets this threatens for structures
this threatens a number of things he
recognized early on when he was
campaigning that South Korea is a
powerful state infinitely more powerful
than North Korea and quite capable of
defending itself he recognized that
Japan is also in the same position in
fact if Japan raises its investment in
military power by just 1% Japan will be
number 3 in the world in terms of a
defense budget
he understands that what Northeast Asia
once and needs is stability order and
prosperity not war and I think he's got
the agreement of everyone who counts in
the region it's an amazing statistic
about Japan by the way which most of us
consider demilitarized apparently not
Colonel congressman thank you both very
much